did you see the news on Kerry Lake today
Vivek I did not see it no so she uh her
election contest is going to trial there
are two main accounts out of the ten two
out of the ten it was a chain of custody
and I think do you remember what the
other one was something to do with the
counts but yeah the the one was chain of
custody being broken and I forget what
the other one was I forgot the other one
but what the uh I bring this up because
we were just talking about big Tech
censorship the FBI's government Tech
censorship government Tech censorship
you're right and one of the counts that
Carrie like brought forward that was
dismissed was first amendment because we
saw that Democrats in Arizona I believe
it was Democrats yeah illegal tabulator
configuration that's right so I think
what they argued was that individuals in
government I'll put it that way had made
contact with social media to suppress
certain individuals and that was a First
Amendment violation and thus intentional
interference or misconduct in the
election the judge said no that count is
a dismissed you know because my view of
this is that
yes we can we can see that the 100
button laptop Story the FBI's
manipulation did interfere with the
election absolutely we're seeing poll
after poll now show Regular People
saying if we had known about this story
if we knew it was real we would not have
supported this man for president and
it's substantial enough that some people
are saying if this story wasn't
suppressed many people would have voted
for Trump instead we could uh we could
have seen a different outcome in this
election
with Kerry Lake the judge outright said
well censorship no idea how do we
calculate votes based on that well
that's that's kind of ridiculous because
actually if you look at election law
federal election law you you can't do
certain things as a campaign regarding
social media advertising right because
they see it as a violation so it doesn't
make sense to me that if you're a
candidate you can't spend however much
you want on maybe social media ads but
then social media doing whatever it
wants to censor different things well
that's totally okay right either we
acknowledge the fact that yes social
media and these advertising campaigns
they can sway people's votes and
therefore we need to control how much
candidates spend into it and do all
these work around the super Pacs or we
let social media companies do whatever
they want because oh I mean we can't
really decide how much uh posts might
inter interfere with voting right you
can't have it both ways right I I think
the issue is we look at polls and we say
x percent of people may have voted
another Direction but how do you
actually quantify the impact of these
psyops of this government Tech
manipulation yeah so look I think that
there's you know three layers of legal
issues is a pretty interesting one one
of the Constitutional issues okay if
you're going to work around using the
first Amendment guess what the same
instruments that you use including
companies ought to be bound by the First
Amendment we talked about that already
second is actually I think there's a
strong campaign Finance case here there
is no greater Financial contribution
that Twitter could have made to the
Biden campaign than to have censored the
most damning piece of information on the
eve of the election that is a
constructive campaign contribution okay
so that's that's another legal layer of
federal laws then there's state laws of
just old school people forget this one
Consumer Fraud all right you don't know
the definition of Consumer Fraud is
telling consumers you are doing one
thing such as not censoring speech or
Shadow bending or whatever when in fact
you are doing the exact opposite thing
like SBF FTX all that the news but this
that's outside the political context
right so let's talk about that telling
customers that you're not co-mingling
funds when in fact you are co-mingling
funds that is definitional Consumer
Fraud that's not that different than
what was happening in Twitter telling
consumers actively through public
statements and otherwise we're not
engaged in viewpoint-based censorship
we're not engaged in Shadow Banning when
in fact you're an engagement Viewpoint
bases and Shadow banning all of which is
again the backdrop of forget the legal
issues is this the kind of society we
want to be living in irrespective of
whether or not it was legal that there
are centralized forces both in
government and in the Deep corporate
apparatus of the private sector that are
working hand in hand to suppress the
will of the everyday citizen the
question you asked was where's
accountability though okay and and I I
have a very very clear view on this
this systems of accountability include
the very same little three-letter
acronymus soup that's responsible and
infested in the first place it actually
starts with
who sits in the Oval Office the next
cycle around and by the way equivalent
for State Governors across this country
we need a government where the people
who report to the chief executive can be
fired by that chief executive this is
why I'm shocked this is not at the top
of a GOP agenda reforming these Civil
Service protection statutes that say if
you work for somebody you are eligible
to be fired by that person I've actually
so one of my big one of our successful
chapters of my biotech Journey was
actually by doing business in Japan we
did a three billion dollar deal at the
end of 2019 I spent countless days that
year in Japan and the funny thing in
Japan it's true in Japanese Pharma it's
true in almost Japanese corporate
Japanese corporate is that even if
you're the CEO of the company you can't
actually fire the guy who's the head of
your research division or the head of
your commercial division turns out that
that means if the C CEO says this is the
direction that the company's going if
the guy who's running research doesn't
agree with you he's going to keep doing
whatever project he was working on
before anyway because if you can't be
fired it means you don't really work for
the person who you elected who was put
in that position so that's in the
corporate context it's not any different
in the governmental context we need to
make sure that the people who we elect
to run the government
are the people who run the government
and I personally think this is one of my
big disappointments in Donald Trump is
that you have a guy who will complain
and identify the problem in a lot of
ways but will complain about Anthony
fauci we'll complain about James Comey
doesn't fire them when the thing you got
to do is very simple yeah you fire them
you fire the legions of people who work
for them you fire the managerial
industrial complex underneath and around
them that is accountability because
otherwise any legal battle isn't going
to sort this out that is what draining
the swamp looks like and that's what
it's going to take place he should have
done that but I I don't mean this to be
a defense for him because he should have
done it regardless but anytime he would
make these staff changes the media would
of course paint it as him trying to
ensure that individual's pledged loyalty
to Trump that he was some kind of
fascist dictator when really I don't
think it's too much to ask that if you
work for a president you should be on
board with the president's agenda but
that was absolutely how the left was
spinning things anytime did Trump did
make staff changes but but then you just
turned the media into fourth branch of
government that he's reporting to yeah
they were saying that anyway right now
regardless what he did they were saying
he was a fascist anyway so there was no
reason for him to capitulate I think he
loved the media too much and tried to
appease the media way too much because a
lot of these policy shifts especially
with the DHS happened under his watch it
was also him that approved gain of
function work in Wuhan China before this
whole entire debacle a few years ago it
was his administration that pushed a lot
of this stuff that now we're dealing
with that was turned against him as he
had users he had people on his staff
saying hey they're going to censor you
hey they're censoring all of your top
supporters all the people who got you
elected all the people who worked so
hard on the internet spreading memes
talking about you they're all slowly
being eviscerated and that circle is
coming closer and closer to you he
ignored it Jared Kushner told him to
shut up and to just play ball he did and
then we're here
to the executive order uh in regard to
how section 230 could be enforced
essentially saying that a platform would
have to pick between being a platform
and a publisher I thought it was a very
a good executive order wasn't really
changing the policy and we can go into
them but no one ended up challenging in
court so it was useless but I'm just
talking about running I'm just talking
about running an organization running a
government you run a company you know I
run a company people have run countries
whatever it is there's a simple
principle if you run the organization
you decide who works there and who
doesn't work there period and a good
litmus test of whether our leader is
doing it I don't care if it's a CEO of a
big company I don't care if it's if it's
the chief executive of a country if you
are complaining to the media about the
people who work for you that means that
you have already failed because if you
had to as the leader of the Free World
complain to third parties who write
about you that means you already didn't
do your job because the people shouldn't
have been there in the first place I do
think the Civil Service protections need
to be repealed I do think that actually
you know what if you're president United
States you can't work for the federal
government for more than eight years I'm
not sure that the people who report to
the president of the United States
should be able to work for the federal
government for eight years actually I'm
sure they shouldn't but even still I
don't think you need to wait for
congress I think article two of the
Constitution says that those Civil
Service protections are basically
unconstitutional anyway if you run the
federal government then dog on it run
the federal government and whoever sits
in that office next that is not Joe
Biden whoever that might be I don't care
if it's a Democrat Democrat Republican
democrats should be every bit as bone
chilled by what happened as Republicans
the same demand year premature upset
with what James Comey did with what they
see is tilting the scales back in 2016.
this is not a Republican or Democrat
issue it is the fact that whoever we
elect it might even be the guy I want I
don't care I'd still rather the guy I
didn't vote for be the guy who runs the
government rather than actually have
somebody else who runs the government
who temporarily does what I want them to
do when it was actually somebody who
nobody elected that is account that is
what accountability looks like and I'm
surprised not enough Republicans right
now are even talking about that as a
solution it's probably going to be Biden
and fetterman with the way things are
going and let's be honest here
2024. they fortified the elections I I
don't see Republicans winning especially
when it comes to ballot harvesting
especially when it comes to all the
things that they have kind of enshrined
themselves with and I think the main
reason Democrats aren't doing anything
is because they're winning they're
they're the intelligence agencies are
using them right now and they're of
course benefiting greatly they're
getting all the seats in in the Congress
in the Senate they're getting the
presidency and most likely you will
still get the next presidency and
probably control politics for the next
few decades unless something drastically
changes which I don't see it drastically
changing well it's interesting if you
look at all the quote anti-establishment
leftists who traditionally would have
been against operation Nations covered
by the FBI against the American people
you would think that a psyop like this
would would upset them but what we see
is because the outcome happens to be one
that they favor and that it's censoring
their opposition they're silent right
because the the old song and dance used
to be oh it's a private company they can
do what they want now that it's been
revealed it's actually not just a
private company there's State
involvement now they're saying oh well
you shouldn't have the right to do that
spread quote unquote misinformation or
hate whatever they want to call it in
the first place so I mean what we see is
that people say that you know leftists
have double standards is actually one
very consistent standard if it helps me
it's good and so that's why we see so
many people who again like actual
progressives who should be anti-fbi
running cover for the swamp I don't mean
to get to like you know uh abstract here
but
here's a pattern I see in the moment we
live in in general okay people are
addicted to the drug you will give them
here here the drug is that you give the
the leftist here as you as you call it
is the outcome you want so we will
violate whatever procedural Norm we
clearly held near and dear to our heart
if we at least get to the place we want
to in the short run by the way that's
the same human into a intuition that led
these social media companies to get as
powerful as they did you give something
away for free that's the other thing
people will flock to it people forget if
you get something for free that you're
the product yes you are not the consumer
you are the product but we have this
cultural moment we live in that as long
as you get that that it's like a little
hamster on the wheel as long as you get
that little jolt that serotonin surge
that that experience of satisfaction you
are willing to trade off the thing that
in your deeper Soul matter to you over
the long run be it your data be it your
privacy in the case of index funds I
mean this is what I spend my day job
your right to express yourself as a
shareholder in Corporate America give an
index fund away for free they'll say
fine I'll hand over my vote get you know
the idea that actually I care about
autonomy and individual procedural
Justice I'll give that away if you
actually put my guy in office we live in
this in this deeper cultural moment
where the everyday citizen is so effect
so weak-willed that we will trade off
the thing that we know we care deeply
about for some short-term outcome and
that's what the managerial class is
exploiting like I don't even see this as
a left and right issue it is a battle
between the managerial class the
bureaucrats who staff the middle layers
of for our universities to our
government to most large companies in
the private sector the managerial class
is able to give the masses what they
want like feeding cocaine to a drug
addict but because that drug addict is
willing to accept it the managerial
class is able to wield its power and I
just think that's the defining to me
it's less about left and right it's more
about this managerial technocracy and
bureaucracy versus the everyday citizen
because the everyday citizens inner
level of fortitude was so lacking that
they were able to be bribed into it in
one sphere of Our Lives from another and
that's what I see happening you talked
about how you know Democrat and
Republicans should both be concerned
about this excuse me but I think what I
see with Democrats and Republicans is
all they want to do is the bare minimum
to maintain power to stay in office to
have a job they don't actually want to
do anything that could harm them so what
we see with Republicans is
throw the bare minimum out there for you
know the red meat to the base stay in
office say what you got to say the
Democrats of course have a more fervent
base with many of these younger leftists
so they're forced to actually try and
give them a little bit more even though
they don't want to I think if Democrats
Republicans had their way they'd sit
back and never say another word and just
keep getting their paychecks so so long
as you have on the left this uh I don't
know Zeal and energy then you're going
to keep seeing Democrats more in line
with this or as Luke put it the FBI is
using the Democrats they're winning
they're getting power they're in line
with it and then you have some
Republicans who are speaking up but it's
only some I guess my point on all that
is
it sure it should be a problem for
Democrats and Republicans but I don't
think they're actually there in the
fight or concerned about anything I mean
maybe there's like 10 members of
Congress who actually care yeah see I've
got a slightly different theory in the
Twitter files leak I think there
actually was maybe one Democrat
representative yeah that expressed
concern about it and I was actually kind
of impressed about how many world
leaders including the likes of Angela
Merkel I I think uh Express concerns for
the freedom of speech of course none of
them said anything publicly because we
can't seem to be citing uh publicly with
Donald Trump in any way even if it's
just defending uh freedom of speech but
I I was I don't want to say pleasantly
surprised but it was like oh okay yeah
there's that yeah I mean that's that's
part of the reason why I don't I mean
even Bernie Sanders has been actually
give this guy credit about whatever a
year year and a half ago was the first
person on the left to say that he did
not and nobody and nobody dislikes
Donald Trump more than Bernie Sanders
based on what he said but that he
doesn't want a fourth branch of
government in Silicon Valley deciding
who doesn't doesn't get to speak to the
American public and so is I don't I
think what you said is descriptively
true but I I would there's a lot of ways
you could a lot of lenses you could
bring to describe the same phenomenon I
bring a different lens which is that
it's not even the left wing and the
right wing lens I think what the left
does better today is that they feed
that generational hunger for a cause
like I told you all right we have this
vulnerability in entire generation of
Americans to latch on to what someone
sells us that's the cocaine for the drug
addict well one one form of cocaine for
the drug addict is religion for a drug
addict who actually lacks religion in
the first place I mean the things that
used to fill the void of human purpose
right you could debate what it is right
patriotism Faith hard work family pick
your favorite fill in the blank whatever
they are they've disappeared in Modern
Life and I think what the left has done
effectively is at least to feed that
vacuum with picurism you know wokism
climatism covetism whatever the ism is
they've come up with modern secular
religions that fill that void and I
think that the right where where the
right is actually failing is what you
call the fervance I think that was the
word you use well the right could tap
into that fervance if we actually had an
affirmative alternative that can fill
that void of purpose and meaning and I
think instead we're myself included or
just taking you know playing a game of
whack-a-mole taking a jackhammer to one
form of poison at a time instead of
figuring out what is what is the
alternativism maybe it is americanism
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time